en directo a vamos a esta ciudad de
mexico para hablar con nuestro
corresponsal mario carbonell sobre la
indemnización que el gobierno entregará
a los familiares de los 10 mineros que
quedaron atrapados hace casi un mes en
una inundada mina de carbón en el estado
de coahuila las autoridades ex siguen
extrayendo agua del pozo y todavía no
saben nada del grupo mientras sus seres
queridos denuncian negligencia mário muy
buenas noches cuéntenos a qué se debe
esta indemnización y qué dicen los
familiares de los mineros
así es si bien el presidente no se ha
referido a los mineros como ya
fallecidos pues queda implícito al
hablar de esta indemnización y dar los
detalles de la misma él ha dicho que
ésta no será convencional que será una
indemnización extraordinaria no sólo por
el agravio de haber perdido a sus
familiares sino por la situación de
pobreza en la que se encuentra esta
gente es por ello que será una
indemnización más allá de lo que marca
incluso la ley hay que señalar que el
acuerdo de indemnización es con las
esposas de los mineros pero no todos los
familiares están de acuerdo algunos
otros como padres madres hermanos
no están convencidos ellos quisieran que
les entregaran primero los cuerpos de
sus seres queridos y ya después hablar
de indemnización sin embargo este fue el
acuerdo con las esposas e incluso se
levantará un memorial aunque el
presidente ha señalado que este memorial
será una vez que hayan el hallar a los
mineros y que el rescate continuará
mario ahora de qué manera continuarán
estas labores de rescate
han dicho el propio presidente y la
encargada de protección civil laura
velázquez que los familiares han
aceptado ya que sea unos trabajos de
tajo a cielo abierto qué quiere decir
esto que van a comenzar ya a meter
maquinaria pesada
excavadoras para pues planificar el
terreno y van a continuar bombeando el
agua porque aún siguen dados estos pozos
pero es un trabajo que será de largo
plazo al menos seis meses y también
estima que podrían prolongarse hasta
once meses de trabajo con maquinaria
pesada esto
arrancará de manera simbólica el próximo
sábado porque aún no llegan pues todos
estos aparatos toda la maquinaria que
van a vender y pues así así han acordado
con los familiares
este trabajo de rescate en que insiste
el presidente no van a terminar a pesar
de la indemnización y a pesar de este
memorial que se tiene que contemplar